hi I'm just result and I'm a researcher
here at the World Bank
the World Bank is a multilateral
financial institution what that means is
it's a group of different countries who
got together and said one way we can
help fight poverty around the world is
to pool our money together and either
lend or give grants to poorer countries
or various programs and various ways of
helping them to improve the living
standards of the people in those
countries
our role is always to represent people
particularly poor people in these
countries I've talked a lot about what
their experiences what the kind of
problems they face are and what are the
kind of programs that can help improve
their lives I work mostly on health and
education that I love the work I do I
think the part that I most enjoy
actually learning from the populations
we work with in 1998 actually set up a
clinic with my brother who's a
cardiologist in a mountain village in
India I think one of the things that we
were very surprised by was there were
many many healthcare providers around
which kind of went against this idea
that the biggest problem in low-income
countries is a shortage of healthcare
providers let's always keep in mind that
there's enormous variation across the
world and I think that definitely parts
of sub-saharan Africa for instance where
access is an issue particularly talking
about the belt of the Sahara in western
Africa so Chad Togo Venini share you
know Burkina Faso I think access like
you comment but for a lot of the other
world it's not so you think about India
the average village has about n
healthcare providers in it then you say
well look it's not access we're talking
about with the laughter of closing
healthcare providers what we are talking
about access is guys who are fully
qualified doctors they say well of
course access is an issue because look
fully qualified doctors there's only one
every five villages then I come back to
you and say don't you have the idea that
a fully qualified doctor is a high
quality doctor and the moment you say
yes I have because then I can say well
do you have any evidence for that and
that's what I bring forth to say a fully
qualified doctor in the public sector is
worse than the guy who's not qualified
in the private
so I think people always have in the
back of their mind access with quality
with the mistake that's being made time
and again is they equate qualifications
with quality and once we can break that
mental model I think we're through I
think we're all talking about the same
thing and it's just semantics